Salve a tutti ragazzi benvenuti in
questo nuovissimo episodio di Hogwarts
Legacy molto probabilmente questo
ragazzi Sarà l'episodio conclusivo Cioè
nel senso non è che io lo giocherò tutto
a Hogwarts Legacy Anche perché adesso
da con Oggi è uscito dovrebbe essere
uscito quindi insomma ho voluto portarvi
in anteprima quanto possibile Poi
ovviamente ho questa Legacy è un gioco
che si presta molto a i video Ma la
storia è molto lunga Quindi se fosse un
gioco con una storia di tipo della
durata di 6-7 ore 8 al massimo avrebbe
avuto senso però così siamo indietro fa
un miliardo di video però giochi come
tipo residentivole eccetera Quelli li
porterò dall'inizio alla fine perché
sentivo quattro remake Quando uscirà lo
porterò all'inizio alla fine perché ehm
possono essere finiti in un tempo
decente voglio dire anche per realizzare
un tot di contenuti video detto questo
proviamo ad andare avanti e vediamo che
succede Let's go e devo finire la
missione Ciao Posso usare il manichino
da addestramento Certamente vado a
prenderlo e ti do un elenco di
combinazioni su cui eseguire Grazie
gentile
magari un manichino assicurati di
lanciare tutti i tuoi incantesimi prima
che il manichino atterri va bene
interrompere l'allenamento prima di
averli finiti tutti fammelo sapere
Ok quindi devo picchiare il manichino va
bene Avada qualcosa ad esempio vado
Ah devo fare quel di quelli in sequenza
ok
È solo questo cioè c'è solo Accio che
posso fare questo è Leviosa
Che bella la mia bacchetta raga Madonna
Da quando l'ho cambiata è bellissima
e c'è solo questi posso fare non è che
TAC e poi un bel laccio a cazzo
Ah perché di cui combinare Quindi uno
può fare ledioso Ecco questo non lo
sapevo ad esempio io sto male ragazzi
i propri punti deboli in allenamento che
in un vero duello che ti sfiderà farà
meglio a temerti
Ok
vado si può andare dalla professoressa
visto che ho fatto una missione qua
Ok teoricamente mi dovrebbe avere
sbloccato oltre che a livello nuovo
dobbiamo andare qua qua Let's go my
friends Non vedo l'ora ragazzi di andare
nel reparto video tutto sto casino solo
per il reparto proibito lo sto facendo
Eh che è la parte che mi interessa di
più in tutto il gioco Spero di andarci
di notte
allora
quindi lezioni incantesimi di sotto non
posso aiutare nessuno ho da fare cazzi
tuoi
poi tra l'altro per andare a piani di
sotto non c'è tipo la polvere volante
direttamente qua non c'è una stanza
sbloccabile
Sì poteva andare eh perché mi sono
teletrasportato così lontano sono
stupido sono stupido io per te so perché
mi hai fatto 30 aspettare Ah perché ero
in cima sono stupidi io mi teletrasporto
senza controllare l'altezza
nuova
deve aiutarti Zenobia Mi dispiace prof
ho fatto fuori tutti gli studenti
ho completato tutti gli incarichi che mi
aveva sentito tutti Allora dovresti
essere pronto a imparare incendio posso
dare fuoco alle cose non vedo l'ora Ho
visto troppi colleghi in cauti finire al
sammugo Per non sapere che il fuoco e un
servitore capriccioso
ma non perdere la concentrazione va bene
vedrai che non finissi la lezione
odierna con gli abiti in fiamme;
cominciamo E ricorda concentrati sui
movimenti corretti della bacchetta va
bene
salta la bacchetta Sì però proprio io
vorrei imparare all'ora Voglio
scassinare i forzieri e gli averi degli
altri si può fare questa cosa ad
Hogwarts una volta insegnare per favore
invece no solo roba per dare fuoco e per
ammazzare la gente roba superata ormai
passata di moda grazie e
ok
Ah giusto perché Madonna quanti Ah ma me
li fa vedere mi fa vedere l'incantesimi
che posso sbloccare ancora Eccoci qua
allora non l'avevo Visti così arresto
momento un bellissimo
glacius Cos'è glacius con già i nemici
Cioè è chiaro
trasformazione Ma questo qua è l'icona
di per il sole splendente per il fior di
corallo stupido topo diventa giallo Flip
flipando cioè flipando ragazzi flipando
era del primo gioco di Harry Potter sto
male
descendo ok
depulso Accio va bene
conflingo ecco questi sono anche
tantissimi danno conflingo Diffido
Expelliarmus bombarda ehm incendio va
bene dopodiché abbiamo disillusione
Vabbè questi abbiamo già sbloccati
Allora Lumos Ciao amore Lumos e riparo
Wingardium
è levioso fai vedere oggetti nemici
mingardium Leviosa far evitare esposto
oggettino
Ah quindi non è Wingardium Leviosa
levioso va bene
il casino di vocazione si è lanciato una
stanza della necessità che era dal nulla
degli oggetti ok
incantesimo alterante Hunter Hunter
e poi evanesco e poi quelle di sotto le
riconosco dal dalle icone abbiamo
imperio la maledizione senza perdono
costringe temporaneamente il nemico
combattere al tuo fianco
crucio efficacia della maggior parte dei
nemici inficiano il dolore alla Croce
però guadagni nel tempo e come ultimo
Avada Kedavra uccide Alessandro i nemici
quindi c'è la vada che dabra ragazzi
bellissimo sto male allora Secondo me la
cosa che serve di meno in questo momento
è che ho usato di meno in assoluto il
lumus No reparo forse ovviamente al
posto di
[Musica]
my friends va bene Anzi facciamo così
guarda
questo X no aspetta questo x e questo
quadrato facciamo
Per me è meglio così ma che il quadrato
mi sa più di cattivo
vediamoci
Beh di questo passo una vada che avrà
non è niente capite no
Vediamo se riesco a fare un incendio
tipo qua in genere
qualcosa no Ho acceso due robe non mi ha
dato mi ha dato premio cose Va bene vado
via Ritorno a lavorare nel prossimo
video Ok il momento di fare le cose
giuste Allora innanzitutto andiamo sulla
torre
del professor FIGC Ecco qua dov'è
no avrei perso il figlio
stiamo per fare cose giuste ragazzi
adesso che c'ho l'incendio mi sembra
corretto è un lumus che ci ha creduto di
più incendio comunque Allora
[Musica]
professore Guardi cosa ho imparato
Boh Mi scusi
Vabbè volevo farlo qua dentro che lei
sta qua Ah Non c'è ancora lo devo
aspettare Posso rifare
Fate attenzione però non so perché mi
parla ma non c'è strano non sia spawnato
poi lo aspetto e compare
mi vede steso per terra a dormire mi fa
Ah ah
invece chiamare l'ambulanza sarà lieto
di sapere che ho lavorato alle mie
abilità difensive con la professoressa
Eca ne vuole un esempio tu potevi
mandare la foto i capelli con la
bacchetta nuova Grazie proprio devi
continuare a esercitarti con lei e con
gli altri professori per migliorare le
tue ambizioni
bene Andiamo avanti mi sa che c'è un
oggetto
il suo programma aspetterà così come
anche il suo studente
aveva dato io avrò
to
Che palle
Che palle questo qua Oh minchia
rimpiangoo silenzio tantissimo
non abbiamo scelta non sarebbe saggio
provocare ulteriormente il nostro
illustre presidente
agli obblighi che mi attendono Io vabbè
posso questa roba qua dietro cos'è che
la vedo luccicare da un'ora e mezza
Boh
Quindi che facciamo parla con Sebastian
Che minchia hai detto Ah Sebastian sì sì
sì sì
Il magico il grande irreprensibile
Sebastian Quanto è lontano
magari
vado io senza Madonna Ma che bella
statica che c'ho raga' Scusate Qua
ogni volta ma non riescono ancora è
bellissima è stata unica che ho ragazzi
è veramente bella non me la voglio
togliere mai ma ecco non ho capito bene
se si può usare l'aspetto di un altro
vestito quando ne usi un altro quello
Spero di sì ciao
Sebastian Eccoti qui speravo proprio di
vederti ero i tre manici di scopa dopo
l'attacco dei Troll e ho visto cosa è
successo con rockwood e arlo non capita
spesso che uno studente attiri
l'attenzione di Victor router Cosa
voleva da te non lo so forse i miei
occhiali
non ci conosciamo neanche deve avermi
scambiato per un altro studente continua
o poi dovrai dirmi cosa sta succedendo
potresti avere bisogno di me ma non lo
voglio io Questo è una squadra mi sta
sul cazzo mi stavi cercando una cosa per
il professor [__] ma è nel reparto
proibito della biblioteca
non può fare da solo è stato convocato
da Black all'ultimo minuto Forse potrei
aspettare di ricevere un suo messaggio
Ma vuoi dimostrare di avere iniziativa
Esatto
E tu hai detto di essere abbastanza in
gamba da non farti scoprire nel reparto
proibito e lo ripeto raggiungimi davanti
alla Biblioteca stanotte
era esattamente quello che volevo da
tipo 8 ore Oh finalmente andare a
Hogwarts in giro di notte e la cosa che
mi interessa mi fa salto temporale
direttamente
me lo fa
ci sono i Prefetti in giro
la porta che dobbiamo raggiungere
e quei fastidiosi dei Prefetti non
aspettano altro che denunciarci alla
scribner Quindi non farti vedere da
lontano è tutto si risolve andiamo
c'è una magia che dovresti imparare
l'incante
Simo
purché te ne resti a distanza e in
silenzio vuoi dire che potrò veramente
diventare invisibile qualcosa del genere
non è infallibile come un mantello Ma
quelli sono costosi mentre gli
incantesimi così prova
ragazzi dovrei imparare tutti ma poi ma
sono tanti sono veramente tanti
vamos proviamo
[Musica]
Aspetta che hai visto ho visto una
pagina che girava prima
[Musica]
per evitare il rilevamento delle aree
proibite Ah è tipo
è una semi invisibilità Però comunque
devo devo andare dentro perché sennò mi
vedono ok
[Musica]
va bene quindi devo assegnare
disillusione Aspetta un attimo che non
ce l'ho segnata
vamos Let's anche qua proprio
deve essere vicini percepiranno il punto
interrogativo
ok
E ma che faccio
ci vado dall'altra parte
non ho ben capito come funzioni sta roba
Sinceramente ragazzi
Ci riusciranno
ce l'ho fatta Secondo me ce l'ho fatta
ma non ho capito bene come
ma lì come passo
aspetta anche questo è difficile
piano piano piano piano piano
è un'invisibilità finta Accidenti la
bibliotecaria è ancora qui presto dietro
la libreria quale libreria questa
libreria
Bellissima sta roba raga
ho detto
che tu parti vedi la sua scrivania
dietro di me
la chiave è nel cassetto di quella
scrivania senti cosa faremo io creerò un
diversivo per farla allontanare tu
Recupera la chiave Ci vediamo davanti al
reparto proibito
ho detto che ti avrei fatto entrare e lo
farò Però abbiamo detto che ti avrei
fatto uscire la mia parola
sicuramente adesso poi mi fa rimanere
qua dentro come si
No no
cazzo succede
very nice
così entra qua devo fare il giro
dall'altra parte però attenzione che
questa fa il giro strano Ok bene ragazzi
Ho giocato talmente tanto a Metal Gear
che sta roba qua è niente ok Non è stato
poi tagliarla
Meno male che non c'era l'amore da fare
perché non mi avete ancora insegnata
bastardi maledetti interagisce
ti appare più utile di quel che è mi ha
già fregato due volte Mai fidarsi delle
apparenze dico io
Sto andando al tutto invisibile senza
farti scoprire a tirare le figure di
autorità nemici a disposizione
Ah sai che non lo sapevo
io posso distrarre Raga per farti vedere
a quello
E come faccio faccio tipo così
Ma poi scusa i fantasmi che che gliene
fotte ai fantasmi di me di basi I
fantasmi sono neutrali Cioè non
dovrebbero essere di parte non fanno le
spie fantasmi che io sappia Però magari
non lo so me la ricordo sbagliato sta
cosa Let's go Madonna quanto grosso sta
biblioteca ma ci posso tornare quante
volte voglio in biblioteca io qua Cos'è
che stai cercando sto cercando una cura
per mia sorella gemella Anna così potrà
tornare a Hogwarts visto che gli altri
sembrano averci rinunciato perché pensi
di trovare la cura nel reparto proibito
La direttrice dell'infermeria di oggi
no abbiamo interpellato chiunque
dall'infermiera bleni al San Mungo Ah
vedi che adesso forse riesco a capire
500 monete
a faccina raga
Adesso sì che Bonucci ho pensato che
poteva fare ste cose
Oh questo è il reparto proibito ragazzi
lo riconosco vorrei usare l'humus ma
l'ho tolto
e levioso qua no
sei di 8 noise
very nices my friend Anche qua c'è
forziere attenzione
Sebastian Sello e compagnia che leccano
il naso dove non dovrebbero
ora siete
nei PX non usare
No sono andato pigs
devo fermarlo o quantomeno andare dalla
bibliotecaria con una buona scusa
Aspetta non voglio che ti metti nei guai
per me ci so fare con gli insegnanti
quando si tratta di questioni
disciplinari Secondo me adesso dice
qualcosa tipo con me ora va e buona
giornata
e io rimango male
conosco Ok
Questa armatura Ca [__] l'ho tolto Ah
perché quando tolgono incantesimo è
quello che mi serve allora
disillusione Accio incendio poi incendio
che mi serviva finora Vabbè Mettiamolo
vamos forziere e
qua Madonna
è bellissimo cos'è
Minchia c'è tutto questo comunque ma non
lo sapevo tracce di magia antica
Ecco fatto questa cosa la posso fare
solo io a quanto pare Cioè io solo vedo
la magia Antica quasi solo io quanto
Insomma piatti alto
Ah sono entrato qua Ed ecco qua non ci
entrerà veramente mai nessuno perché
solo con la magia Antica ci può entrare
e io che la Possiedo cioè che posso
vederla posso entrare qua però di base
non c'entrava nessuno quindi Bene bene
Un miliardo qua mi devo andare abito con
motivo cremisi No è più forte del mio
vero minchia no mi piaceva il mio devo
già cambiarlo
mantelli abiti mantelli abiti amica però
leggendari pure questo 7 Eh sì raga c'ha
più attacco Vediamo se è più brutto
ma
ma ma in realtà mi piace di più l'altro
eh però attenzione modifica aspetto
posso mettere questo Yes Ma allora
ragazzi che parliamo poi tra l'altro
Quello si vende a 200 quindi ottimo
è qua siamo in una zona completamente
inesplorata Nel senso che questa me è
Hogwarts credo Cioè siamo
cicciate trasportati perché siamo con la
magia Antica giusto un bel riparo qua
devo utilizzare un teletrasporto Scopri
il segreto davanti come faccio
Devo risvegliare quella Runa laggiù
quella
se non me l'avesse detto non l'avrei mai
azzeccato raga' non lo sapevo come
faceva a saperlo Non avevo la minima
idea
No non ci credo combattere Va bene
Allora forse è un po' di incendio in
faccia glielo posso dire è
minchia lo disintegrata Ma vabbè Ragazzi
comunque
Ma come mai riesco a far ste robe Sì non
ho capito Tipo la mia ultima Oddio
lanciare questo
affascinante
così tantissimo Guarda che Martina
stoevati Jacopo c'è qualcosa in
diaferica ragazzi Ditemi se finora non è
il miglior combattimento che ho fatto
accumulo di magia Antica ma andando a
segno gli attacchi subendo danni e come
riesci a colpire la presenza Eh sì
Quindi ogni tot quando mi si e la barra
in basso a destra nel Mana che dovrebbe
pesare semplicemente perché quando
quell'affare è pieno posso spaccare la
faccina tutti quanti cosa molto utile
questo è quindi sono fortissimo con
quell'affare da Ottimo questo è stato un
ottimo combattimento ragazzi non
molecolati due qua devo fare altri
in giro sempre verso quello sbagliato se
ce ne sono due Io guardo quello che non
mi sta attaccando come abbiamo appena
fatto adesso e me la prendo nel ciapet
ma stavolta no
incendio non gli fa niente a questi qua
ovunque
Ok
tanto mi curo ragazzi Cos'è sta roba qua
forse devo stare qua sopra e girarla
così no forse c'è qualcosa che devo
colpire in giro no qua devo capire un
attimo ragazzi Scusatemi
Forse c'è qualche oggetto che devo
colpire per muovere
staffareccio semplicemente
no
Boh vediamo
Madonna Madonna raga Che figo
Come si fa ad arrivare là Porco demonio
Ah è a tempo stare che ne so mi sono
cagato nelle mutande
minchia e a tempo quindi il ponte Ah non
lo sapevo grazie Scusate mi scusi non lo
sapevo
Meno male a posto Ecco l'unica roba che
non ci sta in tutto sto casino la musica
di sottofondo che è tutta allegra Invece
qua dovrebbe essere di frutta tetra ma
per andare dove Sento la musica come se
fossi a diagonale
la scelta di soundtrack un po'
particolare questa zona qua però va bene
ecco qua Si sono create due cose ma vedi
che ci sono c'è qualcosa qua dentro che
non capisco secondo me c'è tipo mezzo
enigma da superare che non ho capito
Però vabbè vediamo
Forse ho capito
devo fare così
anche
una volta qua deve fare così prima che
crolli tutto ok dovrebbe essere questo
è Vedi che anche quello di prima potevo
prenderlo come ho fatto porca vacca
sapevo di nuovo un'altra roba che vale
di più di questa ma possibile che sto
continuando a trovare roba che vale un
sacco non mi apre il menù ragazzi non so
perché
non mi apre mi mandate strano
devo tornare indietro amici
però di nuovo
non mi apre
volevo provare equipaggiare sta roba non
riesco
Ci sono quasi mi sono troppo fidato
Porca vacca dovevo aspettare Vabbè e non
avevo capito il tempismo strano che
quando cadi non ti toglie neanche la
vita molto strano
Eh mi sono fidato troppo raga di me
stesso Infatti faccio malissimo
ci siamo facciamo forziere
completo Sì vabbè tanto ogni roba che
trovo è più forte Tanto ormai sì tanto
non mi apre il menù No devo combattere
con tutti questi
vabbè allora sarà una battaglia dove ti
sentirò in testa di tutto questo dopo
quest'altro Yes
grazie grazie a tutti devo fare pure
anche voi e lo faccio ripetere
[Musica]
ha ucciso lui l'ha ucciso lui non ho
fatto niente ve lo giuro
ok
Stiamo sporco demonio eh questa moglie
Allora metto un impegno talmente tanto
che ve lo giuro Madonna Guarda Poverino
lo prendo con lui mi sta cuocendo gli
altri
dai capitevi a vicenda Ma guarda che
siete stupidi eh comunque
minchia lo Spoleto questo signore
potevo tenermelo effettivamente però mi
andava di parlare
forse è meglio tenerseli certi
incantesimi per i momenti di crisi
cos'è in cucina con Benedetta Parodi non
so sparo
non so neanche se esiste un libro così
però
pensatoio No Pensa toio no no no no
hai rotto il cazzo
vediamo
voci cinematica questa
sono sempre loro comunque che lasciano
tracce di magia antica
[Musica]
Ah per farmi bere ci sta
fighissimo
un bel aquamanenti e facevi prima però
dettagli
Vabbè anche meno eh ragazzi minchia
questo si fa i Power Rangers
[Musica]
Forse così facile
che cappello terribile Nessuno te l'ha
mai detto vero è veramente brutto
ma brutto forte
[Musica]
lei era la bambina
desideravate vedermi preside Fitzgerald
professor rackham signorina Isidoro
professor
Mi è giunta voce che tu ti stia
ambientando bene
è così ne sono lieta soprattutto
considerando Quante insolito iniziare
dal quinto anno
che anch'io fui ammesso ad Hogwarts al
quinto anno tutti i quinto anno ragazzi
non conosco altri casi come il nostro
indovino
ieri dopo la lezione mi hai chiesto di
quelle belle spirali che vedesti ormai
anni or sono quando visitammo il tuo
Borgo vi ho riconosciuti immediatamente
non so come ringraziarvi per l'aiuto È
stato un piacere e Sì quel giorno Vidi
delle spirali di magia ovunque mio padre
insiste nel dire che devo essermela
immaginato
Infatti non te le sei immaginate
persival e il professor rackham le vede
ma fino ad ora lui era l'unico io non
capisco che cosa sono si tratta di
suspiri o per meglio dire di tracce che
appaiono solo con una specifica magia
Antica ma fatica sono in pochi coloro
che la Sanno usare invero la stessa
Hogwarts è un baluardo della Magia
Antica Quindi se riesco a vedere questa
magia Antica vuol dire che posso usarla
con la giusta preparazione Ma non è il
caso di avere fretta signorina
prima che io possa addestrarti a una
tale magia deve riuscire a padroneggiare
tutto ciò che Hogwarts può offrirti
una magia del genere può essere dannosa
nelle mani sbagliate deve essere usata
solo da pochi prescelti
Pertanto ti chiediamo di non svelare a
nessuno ciò di cui abbiamo parlato oggi
no raga questo è cattiva
non so c'è la soundtrack un po' Ivo
Quindi secondo me potrebbe essere
Non lo so lei dietro tutto questo casino
non lo so ha strutturato indietro di
tutto ciò
ma adesso in colpa a me io lo scopro e
guarda che Laura
mettevo proprio che sarò costretta a
riferirlo al preside detto questo
tuttavia Pix mi ha detto che non sei
venuto da solo questa sera
se qualcuno ti ha costretto Ti esorto a
dirmelo
sei intelligente
fare questo dono
non c'è nessuno Ah sono da solo anche
perché non potevi dire Lorenzo Ostuni
visto che non penso l'abbiano doppiato
bravo non ha fatto la spia sono Sono in
debito
Eh sono andato Vabbè
bene quindi sblocchiamoci biblioteca
Simone adesso me ne stanno in giro come
se niente fosse già tutto crede mi fai
aprire Oh minchia che prima ho sbloccato
di tutto che ho sbloccato qua
abiti cos'era
No cosa ho sbloccato che avevo guardato
tutte accessori erano No una sciarpa che
è molto migliore di quell'altra
Serpeverde a quanto pare Vabbè
hanno il completo ecco cos'è era non era
Ah meno male non era tunica Minchia se
no È incredibile Questa qua uniforme di
lana
Vabbè ok
Bene
benissimo ragazzi sono troppo forte e
troppo contento Ora che l'avranno Come
si esce di qua Let's go Allora riferire
al professore che si infuriarà con me no
perché sono andato nel reparto privito e
ha rischiato la testa sinistra professor
Black ci fa un culo così io eh Però
intanto gli dico che cosa ho visto
poca Bellissima la trama La trama oltre
ad essere figo il gioco è bella pure la
trama Cioè nel senso non vedo l'ora di
andare avanti per scoprire cosa succede
questa cosa la magia Antica è fantastico
Sono troppo contento
alle volte Comunque non conviene
teletrasportarsi anche se a di è
distante perché il tempo di aprire la
mappa è tutto faccio prima di andare a
piedi
però non so come salire scale quindi
forse era meglio stare da trasportarsi
Però vabbè c'è un gatto devo
accarezzarlo
sono cose essenziali non erano capite
che è importante per me fare queste cose
quindi non mi giudicate Grazie
arrivederci esatto
di su
comunque Ecco l'unica roba è
l'assegnazione delle magie perché alla
fine non puoi mettere solo quattro Che
ci sta
però ci fosse modo per cambiarla ancora
più in fretta perché sono veramente tipo
oreparo lumus cioè conviene averne una
di un tipo Comunque ogni volta non
metterne due di uno stesso tipo
Secondo me Tommy e tribolazioni ok
Salve signor presidente
ci sono visite sono entrato da un'ora e
mezza ragazzi cioè veramente
Minchia signori
Black ciò che cercavamo era un libro
cosa ma è un attimo sei entrato nel
reparto proibito Ma come
Ripensandoci forse è meglio che mi
risparmi i dettagli Forse è meglio il
libro si trovava al di sotto del reparto
proibito Come si vedeva
tutto adattabile diamo un'occhiata
[Musica]
No non mi ha cazziato Comunque pensavo
di sì
sembra che manchino alcune pagine
preparo Qualcuno ha messo le mani sul
libro prima di noi
dovrò accontentarmi di studiare Quel che
resta forse possiamo ancora ricavarci
qualcosa di utile ma servirà tempo
Mi chiedo che ci facesse qui sotto
Hogwarts penso di saperlo io ho visto
altri due ricordi là dove ho trovato il
libro Un altro pensaio per Godric l'uomo
che abbiamo visto poc'anzi persival
rackham insegnava qui nel primo ricordo
c'erano lui e altri tre professori che
usavano la magia Antica per salvare un
borgo dalla siccità Miriam aveva ragione
e nel secondo ricordo parlavano con una
studentessa che aveva iniziato dal
quinto anno come me poteva vedere anche
lei le tracce della Magia perché proprio
quei ricordi magari ce lo spiegherai il
libro Ora dovrò portarlo con me a Londra
il preside insiste affinché vada a
parlare della morte di George
direttamente con il ministero
Ok mentre lei non c'è cercherò di
ottenere maggiori informazioni sulle
pagine mancanti bene non trascurare gli
studi migliori a vista d'occhio con la
bacchetta Grazie prof non vedo l'ora di
imparare l'incantesimo quelli per
ammazzare la magia
di incantesimi avrò molto di cui
occuparmi mentre lei non c'è hai fatto
un lavoro eccellente al mio ritorno mi
farà vedere tutto quello che hai
imparato Non vedo l'ora però tutto
questo quanti Che voti mi ha dato Finora
ti sorprenderà a scoprire quanto può
imparare anche da loro va bene
scusate devo farlo Vabbè ciao
Ok Allora vediamo di andare via di qua
prima che qualcuno chiama la polizia Ti
auguro Più che altro Salve
come dico sempre io meglio fuori che
dentro non quello è Shrek Vabbè
Leggi la posta
Che palle questo che palle che palle
Luca albrato Ho fatto il culo a 60 volte
basta
vabbè
sì comunque va bene tutto lui eh
vedete le lettere sono WhatsApp ci hanno
WhatsApp però
questi sono vocali messaggi vocali è
tipo una strilletta ma non strilla Natti
ti avrei invitato inviato nella posta
via gufo chi chiedono di incontrare Ci
sono già stato L'altro giorno c'è ieri
cioè oggi sempre questo video però
penso fosse ieri nel gioco
Va bene allora la mappa generale ci sono
già stato so dov'è qua ho anche già
sbloccato il posto
mappa
posso andare subito tanto qua
la campagna generale
Eccoci ho sbloccato la polvere volante
qua no
solo lui è sotto il segnalino Ok via
esplorare server perché sblocco le cose
prima così poi posso andarci molto più
Fest Let's get un vero piacere vederti
Sì ma c'è un tizio nella palude non so
se l'hai visto Ah no sul ponte fai
vedere un attimo che mi interessa sta
roba schifo
Ok è sparita la libellula No volevo fare
questo da un tipo una vita
si può andare c'è qualcosa lì però
secondo me è sempre qua muoio Perché c'è
un coccodrillo grosso
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no Oddio e le trappole Si può
notare è bellissima sta roba se non ci
fosse quell'affare
ma lo posso
non lo fa colpire
dug Bog delle Rio foro
se sto notando non posso combattere una
roba o l'altro questo qua non si
immergermi ragazzi
e sta fermo quello lì eh che posso
se qua
segnalino capovolgendo blog sulla
schiena e ho capito che faccio Ahia
Porca [__] che male ahia capovolgi E
come lo faccio capovolge sulla schiena
Vai via nuota nuota veloce veloce quanto
tempo prima
sorella morta incendio nell'acqua
incendio con un genio va bene
vieni qua adesso starci di culo Questo è
il salto del mio livello raga eh
capovolgi non funziona niente Leviosa
incendio non fa nulla
da nulla Lo porto solo a bacchettarlo
così finché non schiatta vabbè
Thank you sconfiggi
Ma ci hanno un loot tipo se vado là
dalla prima volta che faccio fuori un
qualcosa in giro c'è un lupo Ciao
facciamo un segnalino Cerca Eccolo qua
Oh porca ha capito un infarto Mi sono
quasi affogato cos'è a cappotto della
nobiltà ho trovato un cappotto che dello
stesso livello del mio mi sa perché non
mi ha dato niente di più né di meno bene
Scusate mi interessava vedere sta cosa
che non avevo ancora fatto fuori tipo
nessun mostriciattolo gente fuori perché
comunque però l'ho giocato solo ad
Hogwarts non sono andato troppo in giro
quindi vabbè però
bellissimo Comunque Fighissima sta roba
ricordatevi di non utilizza la bacchetta
né altre prenotate perché non potete
farlo è un vero piacere anche per me è
Nazzari come stai Spero tu ti sia
ripresa dalla nostra movimentata gita
stop
Spero che ora mi rivelerai perché ti
stavano cercando Sì sì adesso te lo dico
Non ho idea
all'inizio del gioco Raga non ho detto
niente a nessuno
è un po' strano che entrambi cerchino
uno studente di Hogwarts con tanta foga
perché sono interessanti
per tutti in effetti Ecco perché volevo
parlarti quel giorno Aux Mid ho capito
una cosa hai mostrato grande Coraggio
nell'affrontare quel troll e sirena non
si è lasciata intimidire da rock
wonderlo mi avete ispirata a prendere
posizione proprio come voi grazie In che
senso
il matabelaland non rimarrò qui immobile
a lasciarli distruggere la mia nuova
casa
Va bene va bene
Una ragione in più per fermarli
al più fragira voce che teofilosarlo o
gestisca le operazioni quotidiane di
rugby eliminando lui disgregheremmo
l'intera organizzazione di rugby
possibile ma non dovrebbe essere la
gente Singer a occuparsi di uno come
arlo ho parlato è stata gentile ma forse
comprensibilmente non vuole discutere di
un caso così con una studentessa ho
sentito alcuni uomini di rookwood
parlare di un enorme operazione di
saccheggio programmata darlo pensavo che
potremmo investigare un po' anche noi
magari ottenere le prove di cui ha
bisogno la gente Singer va bene ma come
mi limiterò a guardare e ascoltare
scoprire esattamente quale sia il piano
di arlo ti ricontatto appena ne so di
più nel frattempo ricorda se ti servo
sono qui praticamente Grazie Natti
fantastico Io andrò a far fuori gente
cioè altri mostri giganti No non è vero
volevo solo vendere prima di andar via
già che ci siamo perché sto tizio qua
penso sia
Ah ho finito la questo Side di Natti va
bene
Ah quindi questa è finito dopo niente a
che fare con lei
devo assolutamente vendere delle cose
raga' Tutto questo gli occhiali sono
rimasti al primo episodio del secondo
episodio forse cioè eri di questa cosa
ok Questo vale quanto il mio però Allora
intanto vendo questo vediamo questo
sblocchi un oggetto poi l'aspetto di
quell'oggetto Ti rimarrà per sempre
giusto
oppure me lo toglie vediamo vi aspetto
sono diverso no Quindi quando io trovo
un oggetto quello mi può rimanere per
sempre a livello di aspetto perché l'ho
appena venduto questo ma ce l'ho ancora
addosso però è un altro oggetto simile
mi troverei bene in un posto piccolo
come questo questo io mi troverei bene
anche a essere chiuso in uno sgabuzzino
del mondo magico quindi Non sputare Nei
piatti
Ok
Ah già minchia Ragazzi allora ancora
tutto questo non l'abbiamo imparata bene
andiamo di là
sono fantastici aiuta la sconosciuta
ragazzi Scusatemi perché c'è una
missione qua
non ho capito ma facciamola
mago oscuro se Indiana Jones
ancora questi Minchia che palle Parli
del diavolo
il signor rookwood
Lasciala in pace e allora maniere forti
non ci avete voglia di combattere Non
fatelo erano lì fermi mi guardavano
Allora facciamo un po' di incendio che
dite Ah ma incendio devi esserci proprio
davanti alla faccia però non gli fa
niente vediamo questo Innanzitutto
è una pietra nelle palle
ma pietra nelle palle la magia e sto in
the Bowl
Da Willy
tua madre morta che male
con questo incendio
sto morendo raga
mi fai fare attenzione perché
Il problema è che sono troppi Raga non è
che posso
Ok ok
una è andata via in un altro Orca
[__] per un secondo non lo schivato
niente Raga ho sempre sfiga Ho sempre
sfiga mi giro sempre nei momenti di fame
non sono ancora morta
sempre sfiga schiaccia triangolo nel
momento sbagliato sempre sempre sempre
cioè proprio mi tira una magia mi
colpisce lo schiaccio un secondo dopo
oppure lo schiaccio prima e mi finisce
il protego proprio mentre mi arriva la
magia in faccia proprio nato sfigato
Vabbè in tutto questo è cambiata la è
più saturato adesso boh forse perché è
cambiato il meteo Sì sì lo so come si fa
Devo solo non avere sfiga però per
questo sto tranquillo
fate fare delle figure di merda e poi
riesco a fare le cose semplicissime
Comunque veramente principio devi stare
proprio di fianco raga cioè incredibile
non mi vedeva nulla
Ok perfetto
c'è anche prima se non avessi avuto
speaker Ma che succede che ne so sei tu
che fai casino
Beh hai finito Ah devo parlare con lei
Scusate non ho capito
Sì è in gran parte e grazie alle tue
eccellenti abilità difensive si può
migliorare
per arrivare a te
il gruppo di ladri e furfanti al
servizio di Victor
mi sembravano molto interessati a te È
una lunga storia ma grazie per l'aiuto
per il momento li hai schivati Pria mi
aveva detto che i pericoli sarebbero
aumentati devo affrettare la mia ricerca
prima che tornino
storica e archeologa specializzata nelle
opere nella vita di Merlino
Ok
Merlino quello di Re Artù proprio lui
Merlino frequentò Hogwarts
strutture che lasciò centinaia
questi pilastri ricoperti di vegetazione
ce ne sono dozzine sparsi ovunque Ho
iniziato a chiamarli le prove di Merlino
presumo li abbia creati come
divertimento per gli altri serpenti era
un Serpeverde Merlino
non sapevo fosse sempre verde Merlino
anch'io sapere qualcosa di più sulle sue
prove allora ti confesserò un piccolo
segreto nessuno ha ancora capito come
funzionino Ma credo di aver appena
individuato un cruciale
sospetto che la malva sia un componente
essenziale per far funzionare le prove
la malva un'erba versatile Merlino la
cita spesso nei suoi scritti ero appena
arrivata per testare la mia teoria
quando sono stata interrotta vedi ogni
spirale tracciata da Merlino un simbolo
diverso al centro e così ho iniziato a
pensare e se la malva si è posizionata
al centro dei simboli esattamente
nessuno subito i risultati di questa
nostra ipotesi
questo baule Sì Prendine un po' Anche se
ne hai già
ho preso l'avrai preso lo stesso a
prescindere ti apro anche gli altri dopo
ti rompo Tutto questo
a terra ogni
Pro due elementi metti la malva sulla
spirale e vediamo che succede ok
Ah quindi per triggerarli mi serve per
forza sta roba figo
cosa devo fare adesso
da qui è tutto interessante
[Musica]
in giro varie moto si dice di queste
immagini fichissimo
[Musica]
c'è anche la silhouette di Merlino
Eh minchia abbiamo fatto una delle
scoperte più grandi di Hogwarts E tu hai
reagito così
sicuramente Tuttavia ora ho ancora più
interrogativi per forza funziona Devo
rivedere i miei appunti forse mi sfugge
qualcosa Le prove sono tutte come questa
cosa
abbiamo le piante rampicanti e la
spirale per terra dovresti poterle
risolvere man mano che le incontri
quanto a me o ciò che mi serve per
continuare le mie ricerche la mia idea è
che ognuna richiederà della Malva Malva
che puoi trovare Aug Smith Qualora ti
servisse ora devo andare È stato un vero
piacere conoscerti Piacere mio a vecchia
grazie
ora che ho tutto ciò che mi serve posso
tornare tranquilla ai miei studi cioè
devo fare sempre il mio saluto finale
alla gente questo bene quindi adesso
abbiamo scoperto che esistono delle
sfide dove io posso sbloccare tipo
perché comunque ti danno un sacco di
esperienza sulle sfide Anche penso
oggetti che sono le sfide di Merlino
fighissimo Bene ragazzi Vabbè Allora ehm
teoricamente non ha senso continuare
ancora perché siamo arrivati quasi
un'ora di nuovo di Gameplay e questo
Hogwarts Legacy raga Cioè vi ho portato
quattro video ho cercato di giocare il
più possibile per introdurvi al mondo
perché vabbè come sapete A me piace
tantissimo il mondo di Harry Potter
quindi Aspettavo questo gioco Cioè In
realtà io mi immagino sempre se avessi
avuto sto gioco da bambino probabilmente
non avrei giocato ad altro Quindi
incredibile Io sono molto contento di
di aver avuto l'onore di portarvelo in
anteprima di giocarlo Addirittura in
anteprima due settimane fa prima ancora
l'anteprima dell'anteprime quindi sono
molto contento di questo e
Spero vi piaccia raga secondo me è molto
figo cioè Spero vi piaccia sembra che
l'ho fatto io il gioco però è perché ci
tengo tantissimo Non lo so Io amo il
mondo di Harry Potter da sempre però
insomma Io ci giocherò ancora un sacco e
magari più avanti portare un Gameplay
Non lo so magari quando avrò fatto un
botto di cose in più ma queste cose
queste queste
gli animali ci posso fare qualcosa gli
animali
Vabbè spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale Io vi dico
porterò Gameplay ancora questo era
un'eccezione ovviamente perché come
sapete non porto più Gameplay però ci
sono quei giochi che fanno eccezione ve
li spoilero già se siete arrivati fino
alla fine del video quindi ai pochi
letti che avranno visto tutto eccetera
poi erano già i prossimi che saranno
residentivol 4 remake Quando uscirà che
uscirà alla fine di marzo quindi manca
ancora un mesetto e mezzo
Sons of the forest ovviamente che è il
prequel di the forest però è il gioco
che sta per uscire quindi il the forest
2 sostanzialmente ed è fighissimo e
vorrei portare ovviamente il terzo
capitolo di Outlast che uscirà più
avanti questi saranno Gameplay che farò
sicuramente ehm interamente Cioè
residents li farò per intero Beh Sons of
the forest non penso di sì però non lo
so perché non so quanto sia lunga la
storia c'è anche la storia di the forest
del primo
molto Open World quindi
non è una non ha una linearità Ecco
quello volevo di tipo Resident Evil Però
ovviamente sono state Forest cerco di
finirlo perché è incredibile Hogwarts
Legacy Ovviamente come vi ho spiegato
prima all'inizio
è troppo Vasto la storia la storia line
è troppo lunga e quindi non avrebbe
senso portarlo tutto però portarvi
quattro episodi belli lunghi in
anteprima mi ha fatto più che piacere
Spero anche voi ragazzi iscrivetevi al
canale lasciate un mi piace come ho
detto prima e noi come sempre ci vediamo
ad un prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]